on appris au cours des derniers jours
que bien peu d'hôpitaux sont équipées
pour faire les tests qui permettent de
détecter le ghb vous savez ce qu'on
appelle la drogue du viol sur une
victime potentielle ma prochaine évitée
si la chanteuse ariane brunet élite ici
pour nous parler de son expérience
malheureuse bonjour ariane alors vous
vous êtes retrouvé à l'urgence de
l'hôpital de verdun la fin de semaine
passée qu'est ce qui vous y arrivez
qu'est ce qui vous a amené à l'urgence
de verdon bond en quelque sorte avec de
la nuit voir un spectacle on avait deux
plaisait un certain moment et je t'aime
même jamais même la conscience d'esprit
de 10 rebonds mais a il faut faut des
sous pour et pourrait pour payer notre
consommation faut que je sorte du bois
faut que j'aille retirer tout se passait
je me rappelle encore très bien je
communique avec mon job puis après si je
commande un verre j'invite mes amis
apprendre le bar avec moi puis c'est ce
vers lequel fait toute la différence
parce que dans les minutes qui ont suivi
j'ai j'ai plus aucun souvenir des
minutes qui ont subi en vite je sais ça
vient vraiment par flash j'ai envie très
peu fait que j'ai très peu de souvenirs
j'ai été très très très malade puis un
certain point mon ami quitte avec moi a
dit mme transporté dehors allez chercher
du renfort parce que je n'étais pas
capable de me soulever tellement j'étais
lourde pesante j'ai un souvenir de ceux
d'être d'être excessivement faisant
comme si j'allais m'effondrer dans le
plancher comme je l'avais pas l'usagé de
mes jambes d'aller chercher du renfort
sur et dehors on est obligé d'appeler
les prénoms des gens alors vous vous
êtes convaincu d'avoir été droguées
parce que les gens qui vont vous
entendre on peut être des petites allées
à des prix vraiment un coup ce soir là
et vous vous êtes sûr que vous avez été
droguées j'en suis convaincu j'ai 31 ans
g bülach quelques tubes plus l'alcool
auparavant dans ma vie et je connais mon
corps c'est ce qui est pas quelque chose
que j'aurais pu dire puis affirmer avec
certitude mettons à 19 ans 20 ans alors
que chez peu c'est moins habiles -
j'en suis convaincu je sais alors vous
avez été transporté à l'hôpital il
l'assure sur place vous avez demandé
qu'on des pistes pour trouver cette
substance qu'on appelle le ghb c'était
pas possible vous at on dit qu'est ce
qu'on vous a donné comme raison
exactement m me réveiller on me laisser
dormir jusqu au moment de passer chez le
médecin en fait dans le bureau du
médecin puis là c'était une star une
médecin interne en fait quelqu'un aux
études encore rigaud qui me répondent
qu'ils me dit bon je n'ai pas cette
information là je vais aller chercher
mon supérieur puis puissance période
puis il me répond à ma question à ma
demande en fait persistante de me parler
des terribles
et adore une prise de sang et puis on
dit écoutez je suis vraiment désolé de
vous apprendre mais on n'est pas
l'équipement nécessaire ici à l'hôpital
de verdun unis dans les hôpitaux de la
ville au complet pour pour les potes de
tout de suite montréal c'est ce qu'on
m'a dit
la ville au complet aucune urgence est
équipé de
ceux des outils nécessaires pour
dépister le ghb ou les dérivés de ce
type de drogue là dans le sens qui est
excessivement volatile il me dit de
toute façon on n'en trouverez pas de
trace de sa fête ça fait trop longtemps
mais pourtant on me rend très rapidement
les urgences c'est que que je m'explique
pas alors l'information qu'on vous donne
c'est de toute façon il y en aurait plus
me faisais pas 12 heures que ça s'était
passé votre
épisode maintenant le spectacle en
question commencé à 10h
jeu tales à 10h30 j'ai dû rentrer à
l'hôpital à minuit 1h puis avant de
rentrer dans l'ambulance mes amis ont
dit aux ambulanciers coûter à lui été
droguées on avait eu la même
consommation d'alcool cette formule avec
avec mes amis puis d'écouter halle était
de rigueur on en est sûr l'information
était passé aux ambulanciers mais mais
il ya peut être prise de sang il ya plus
de de suite à ces caisses qui
visiblement vous êtes une jeune femme
informé alors qu'est ce qui vous faisait
croire que c'était du ghb pourquoi vous
saviez ce réflexe la de demander à la
médecin par ces mois un test de
dépistage de ghb ouais c'est aussi fou
que cela puisse paraître mais comme je
le disais je suis je dois je connais mon
corps et puis j -ja bien auparavant je
savais qu'il y avait une intrusion
quelconque qu'une intoxication
quelconque que j'avais pas choisi puis
et puis je sais pas j'en étais
consciente malgré que j'ai été aussi
affecté puisque bref quand je me suis
réveillé j'ai c'est la première chose
que j'ai demandée puis tu sais j'ai eu
la présence d'esprit de le demander ça
n'empêche que avant ces gens n'avaient
pas j'avais peur usage de la parole de
mes jambes je n'avais pas la vue j'ai
mais au moment de me réveiller
mais mon premier réflexe a été d'appeler
mon manque chez mon mari pour qui qui
est rejoindre parce que j'avais pas
s'ils savaient que j'étais à l'hôpital
j'avais aucune information il rentrait
dans le bureau puis le lui ai dit mon
dieu ça se peut pas juger eu l'histoire
au complet puissesseau est d'abord son
feedback mdi mais le titre était drogué
puis mes amis j'ai été drogué puis
l'avait déjà vu se passait auparavant
avait déjà eu des vents de ce facteur
oui c'est un réflexe de demander mais
qu'est ce que ça maintenant comme
conséquence de ne pas savoir ce qui vous
est arrivé pour vrai merci posé la
question mais oui et c'est même si j'en
suis convaincu que j'ai été drogué puis
sa mort est tellement aidé à passer les
passer au travers les heures qui ont
suivi l'agression de savoir qui est est
cliniquement et scientifiquement et tel
pourcentage dans le sens où juste juste
un oui
par rapport à un point d'interrogation
ça m'aurait vraiment aidé à passer à
travers cette épreuve le pis
c'est juste difficile à expliquer
pourquoi ça aurait fait une science mais
ça aurait fait une différence qui s'est
surtout que je pense aux gens qui se
retrouvent avec une personne dans une
soirée seulement puis où l'agresseur ou
la personne le coupable est vraiment
identifiable mais l'oeil aucune façon
d'en avoir la preuve clinique nous reste
quelques secondes seulement parce que
vous avez bien rien de brûler ce que
vous êtes remise complètement ça veut
mais je me sens encore à 100% moi même
si j'espère que ça va revenir rapidement
c'est pas vrai construit veille de tous
ceux qui peuvent que la vie continue et
le riz non j'ai hâte de retrouver mon
corps ma meilleure amie retrouver tous
vos moyens j'en suis seul mais ce poste
merci beaucoup dans paris on en parle
bien de brunei merci d'être pas son
studio merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]
oh